[Music]
shaking and bacon it's a party
[Music]
welcome back to tasting our roots i'm
vanessa and we're headed to harlem
first stop melba wilson from melba's
restaurant
it was important for me to show kids in
my community that we could create
own and operate right here in our
background to have different age groups
ethnicities religions all sit down in
one restaurant to be able to come
together through food is magical so
let's talk about the dish that we're
making today and what significance it
has to you well we are making one of my
favorite things in the world and it's my
southern fried chicken and eggnog
waffles would she beat bobby flay with i
mean who does that let's go to the
kitchen
my chicken sits and in seasoning for at
least one to two days so when you look
at this chicken you'll see it's already
seasoned cooking for me
is passion we have some black pepper in
there of course a little white pepper
onion powder garlic powder so why did
you choose an eggnog waffle this dish is
so special making breakfast one day for
my son at home he's like mom can you
make some waffles sure sir i look in the
fridge there is absolutely no milk
there's only orange juice and eggnog
girl you know what i did right he's an
eggnog he's eating the waffles he goes
ma these are the best waffles ever
i'm like
the light goes off they're going on the
menu at melba's to create true economic
development it's important for dollars
to circulate within our community at
least eight times
so what i wanted to do was show people
that we can dine in harlem we can shop
in harlem we can live in harlem and we
can love right here in harlem
so this is one of the things that my mom
used to do and i've kind of incorporated
it and then we're going to do the
old-fashioned shake and bake baby
getting a loan for a restaurant is
almost impossible so getting along for a
restaurant in harlem with a black girl
never had a loan never owned a
restaurant before it was almost
impossible so what i did was i saved
money under my mattress it was a little
bit over three hundred thousand dollars
wow i invested it in me as an
entrepreneur it's really important to me
to make sure i have enough and one of my
biggest fears is not being able to save
or make enough to keep growing so in
lieu of advertising one of the things
that i like to do is give back to the
community so just today we donated
waffles for about 40 kids oh wow
do you think that there's a barrier
still occurring in the kitchen as far as
a glass ceiling for people of color and
have you had any experiences of that for
yourself it's definitely really
difficult because people will come in
not expecting a woman and definitely not
a woman of color to be in charge so i'm
always finding that i have to over
extend
and show them hey i'm here and it
shouldn't have to be that way so we're
gonna add powdered sugar okay
nice oh wow you can hear like how
crunchy it is
[Music]
wow
and i love chicken and waffles but just
this concept of this the eggnog the
cinnamon and all that together
so the eggnog chicken and waffles the
flavors were really complex as far as
her putting the nutmeg and the cinnamon
and the eggnog and the waffle but not
too much where it's over saturated then
you have this really creamy strawberry
butter which really complements the
savory and crunchy fried chicken she
added a lot of cajun spices to that so
you got a little bit of heat in your
bite you got a sweet in your bite you
got this nice nuttiness from the spices
in every single bite i love being harlem
so much that i'm so excited to go to our
next restaurant so please join us next
time on tasting our roots
[Music]
oh yes